[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARUI SUN: Welcome to
Best Practices for Privacy
and Security in GCE.
My name is Sarui.
I'm a product manager on
the Compute Engine team.
CACHE MCWHERTER: I'm Cache.
I'm an IAM engineer, and I'm
ready for a 400 level little
talk on the theory
of securitrons.
SARUI SUN: Well,
Cache, you're going
to have to wait just a little
bit because this is a 200 level
talk.
But we still have a lot of
great content for you today.
So I wanted to get started.
So over the past years,
we've learned a lot here
at Google Cloud in securing
both our internal cloud
and the clouds
for our customers.
And the goal of
the next 50 minutes
is for us to share
some of those learnings
for you, to share some
of the best practices
we've picked up so
that you don't have
to make the same
mistakes that we did,
and that you can take
off running when it
comes to securing your cloud.
So often when we
talk to customers,
they'll ask us a question that
sound something like this.
They'll say, hey, how do I
check off that security box?
How do I make sure my cloud is
completely, completely secure?
And to that we say, well,
that's a good question.
And Cache and I got in a
room we thought about it
for a little bit, and it turns
out it's the craziest thing,
you can actually
secure your cloud
with just this one weird trick.
It's pretty crazy.
Are you ready for it?
Just kidding,
that's not a thing.
It'd be crazy.
Wouldn't that be crazy, though?
Like this whole talk would
be over in like two minutes.
In reality what we
found in over the past
years is that
security is a lot more
of a dynamic contextual thing.
So if you think
about it in terms
of securing a physical space
like securing Moscone Center,
the correct level of security
or the correct security posture
for Moscone Center is going to
depend on a number of factors.
It's going to depend
on what part of Moscone
are you trying to secure?
Are you trying to secure
the front sidewalk
or are you trying to
secure the generator room?
It also is going
to depend on what's
happening on Moscone Center?
is this an open house
that anyone can attend,
or there's the president in
town and giving a speech?
And even more, if you are
in charge of the team that's
securing Moscone Center is your
responsibility to just secure
this building, or is it to
secure the entire complex,
or is it to secure a nationwide
chain of convention centers?
That's all going to
be a different part
of the calculation
of the equation
and it's going to change
how you approach security.
And so when you look at
security posture, first of all,
it lies on a spectrum.
Regardless of what
you're trying to secure,
it lies on a spectrum,
and we should recognize
that it can be too loose.
No matter what you're trying
to secure it can be too loose.
It can be the Wild West.
Anyone could do anything
and for sure bad things
are going to happen there.
But it can also be too strict.
You can have too many rules,
too many things locked down.
And that's bad too, because that
will lead to loss of agility.
It might lead to an
antagonistic relationship
between your security
teams and everyone else,
and a number of other things.
And so to start the talk I want
to set aside some principles
to help you try to understand
and navigate the spectrum
and get to the right spot there.
So the first principle
I want to talk about
is centralized administration.
And this is the idea that if
you as a central security team--
there should be a central
security team that
has full awareness of
everything that's going on,
or at least the ability to be
fully aware of what's going on,
and also has responsibility
and governance
and authority to govern over
everything that's going on.
Centralized governance,
without that,
if you don't have the ability
to know what all is going on
or the authority to
enforce what's going on,
you're almost
certainly too loose.
But what we found is if
you just have centralized
administration, you
may end up falling
on the opposite end
of the spectrum,
especially in a
larger organization.
If you have a team of
hundreds or thousands
and the responsibility for
securing and tracking down
everything that's
happening is falling
on the shoulders
of very few people,
you may end up on the
opposite side of the spectrum
where you're forced to
lock down everything
or you're forced to
implement policies
that you can't keep track
of because there's just
so much going on.
And so to that we introduce
a second principle
called delegation.
And this is the idea
that if you have
a centralized administrative
team that they can still
delegate administrative
tasks to a separate sub
team or some other division
or some other set of folks,
and that they can move much
quicker having delegated
authority.
And what we found is that
between those two principles
you're able to get
closer to the center
and get into what we call
the Goldilocks zone--
It's a technical term.
--where you basically
have the right mix
of too loose and too strict.
And notice what we've done
here is we've called it a zone.
This is not a Goldilocks point,
and that's in recognition
that the right place to
pick on the security posture
is going to be very
contextually relevant.
It's going to depend on
the context for your cloud
just as it depended on the
context for Moscone Center.
And so what we're going to do
within this presentation is
we're going to start with the
building blocks for security,
start with some of
the tools there,
and we're going to build our
way up to some best practices
that we've learned.
But by doing so we'll allow
you to kind of pick up
the best practices,
some of which
you should do
regardless all the time,
but the practice of some of
which will depend on what
your security context is and
what's the right security
posture for your organization.
OK.
So the first building
block, starting simple,
are the identities.
This is the set of
users and groups
and services that you have
that Google Cloud knows about.
Google Cloud knows about them
because Google Cloud Identity,
which is our identity
service, knows about them.
The quick thing I'll say
here is that we understand
that some of you may have your
identities mastered elsewhere.
In fact that might
be most of you.
A lot of organizations
that we've talked to,
they master their identities
in Active Directory.
And I just want to call
out that it is possible.
We do support you
syncing your identities
from wherever you master them
into Google Cloud Identity
so that you can
keep mastering them
wherever they currently exist.
Next, I want to talk
about resources.
So these are the things
that you're ultimately
trying to protect.
When it comes to
Compute Engine, these
might be your VMs and your
disks and your subnets
and your images.
But resources also apply to
any non Google Compute Engine
resources inside GCP as well.
Resources, of course, roll up
to one and only one project.
These are our base
level of grouping.
So all resources have
to belong to one project
and projects also encapsulate
some other properties
like the billing account,
quotas, permissions, and things
like that.
The next level up
is the organization.
So this is an optional concept.
You don't have to
have an organization,
but we highly, highly
encourage it for reasons
that I'll get into for a second.
But these will act as the root
node for all GCP resources.
So if you set up an
organization everything
should roll up into
the organization.
And finally, we have folders.
These are an additional
optional grouping mechanism.
They can contain other
projects or folders,
and we found that this is a
great way to organize and make
sense of your policies.
So we're going to dive a little
bit more abstract in a sec,
so bear with me,
but we'll then make
it more concrete with some
examples and some best
practices to put them together.
So once you have the
resource hierarchy in place
you can apply policies to
this resource hierarchy.
Policies can be applied anywhere
in the resource hierarchy,
and once they're
applied, a policy
is then passed from the
parent to the child.
So for example, if I set
a policy on department x
it'll pass down to all the other
sub folders under department
x as the folder that'll get
passed down into the projects
and into the resources.
There we go.
There are two types of policies.
The first one is
called IAM policies.
So these are in the business
of granting permissions
to particular identities
for particular resources.
The second type is called
organization policies.
These are in the business
of creating constraints.
Let's talk about
IAM policies first.
IAM policies control who is
allowed to do what on which
resources.
So it takes a set of identities,
like a user or a group
or a service account, and then
it takes a set of resources,
like a folder or a project
or individual resources,
and it says these identities
will have these permissions
on these resources.
And it does that through
a particular role.
So in this particular
example, we
might give, for example, Alice
the compute instance admin
role on an individual VM.
And what that'll do is it'll
give Alice permissions to do
instance administrative actions
on that VM, like creating VMs
or like creating it,
what's already created,
deleting it, starting
it or stopping it.
So what I find is
that it helps make
things a little more concrete.
If we show what this
looks like in the UI,
you can of course set
permissions in G Cloud
and the APIs as well.
But for the purposes
of this presentation,
we'll go in the UI.
So here I am in the instances
list in Compute Engine.
I can select a particular VM.
Here I've selected instance
1,000, and now that I specified
the resource I just
need to say who
can do what on that resource.
And so if I click the
Add Members button
over in the top right there, I
can answer those two questions.
So it'll ask me who do you
want to have this policy,
and also what role do you
want to apply to this user?
So in this particular
case, I'm going
to give Alice this
particular role,
and the role I'm going to give
is the instance administrator
role.
So that's just walking through
what the previous example
concretely looked like.
Next, the second type
of policy is called
the organizational policy.
So these are in the business
of placing restrictions
on your resources.
And some examples
of that are you
might want to restrict
the specific types of APIs
or a specific set
of services that
can be used in a particular
folder or a project.
You might want to restrict a set
of VMs that have external IPs,
or the third example
there is you might
want to restrict a
set of users that
can be added to IAM policies.
Concretely what
this looks like is
if you go into a project or
a folder or an organization
and you go into the IAM
section and then the org policy
subsection, you can see the full
list of organizational policies
that we support.
And the important thing here
is we offer a lot of them.
We're adding to that
list all the time.
And so one thing we recommend
is just when you're starting
your Clouds appointment
or even if you've already
got going, if you haven't
looked through all of these
just take a look.
It's kind of like flipping
through your iPhone settings
when you first set it up.
Here's a concrete
example of that.
So suppose I'm an administrator
and I want to do my job well,
and part of that is
preventing data exfiltration.
So one org policy
that we find is
very effective in helping to do
that is the domain restricted
sharing org policy.
So what I can use this for is I
can dictate that my developers
they're not able
to share resources
to users outside
of my organization
unless I give them
explicit access to do so.
Similarly, another vector
for data exfiltration
might be external
attacks that go and look
for VMs in my organization
with external IP addresses.
And so another organization
policy that I can set
is one that restricts
the set of VM instances
in my organization with
external IP addresses.
And so I will have knowledge
about all of the VMs
that are in my organization
that have external IPs.
OK.
So let's put this all together.
We're back to the hierarchy.
Resources inherit the
policies that we just
talked about from their parent.
And so we can see
how we can start
to apply some of the principles
that we talked about before.
So the first principle
I talked about
was centralized administration.
You need to give away for some
central administrative team
to understand what
all is going on
and to have some broad
authority over that.
So what you can
do, for example, is
you can have an IAM policy
which gives the compute viewer
role-- this is view
only access to compute
resources. --to your
organizational admin group,
and then once you apply that
policy to the organization
node you'll see that it
flows down to all the folders
and projects and resources
within that node automatically.
And this will apply to
all the present resources
in your organization,
but it'll also
apply to all the future
resources in your organization
as well.
And so you can start to
see how this gives you
a bit of an easier time in
doing centralized administration
because you can imagine if you
didn't have this organization
node, you might be
chasing after thousands
of projects that get spun
up in your organization.
Secondly, we can achieve the
second principle as well,
which is that of delegation.
So if you imagine you
have team A over here.
Team A has an SRE team and as
a centralized administrative
group you want to delegate
instance administration actions
to that particular team so you
can set the policy on team A's
folder to give instance
admin role to the entire team
A SRE group, and that
will also propagate down
to all the projects and
resources under team A.
And so now you've effectively
delegated permissions
for that particular team
for that particular group.
The same thing applies
with org policies.
So suppose I have a
folder and in that
folder is supposed to
categorize a set of workloads
that are internal only.
I don't want these
workloads to ever
have an external IP address,
which I'm showing here
as the internal folder.
I can set a org policy on
that particular folder,
which restricts all VMs
with external IP addresses.
And in doing so I'll find that
the org policy automatically
flows down to all the
resources and projects
in that particular folder.
And so here again I'll
have a much easier time
of governing my organization.
OK.
So that was some of
the building blocks.
I'm going to turn
it over to Cache,
who's going to start building
them up into best practices.
CACHE MCWHERTER: Thanks.
Now, as you might expect we
talk to a lot of customers.
Day in and day out
this is all we do.
We try to help them understand
where they're coming from
and how to apply the security
tools that we're developing
to best solve their
security problems
and manage their cloud.
And one of the common
problems that we have and we
find that customers
have is that they
don't know how to
most effectively apply
the resource
hierarchy to organize
their resources in our cloud.
We find that customers will
sometimes not really know
what to do and they'll end up
with the sprawl of hundreds
or thousands of
projects, all of which
have different
policies and settings
and so forth where
they have to manage
each of these individually.
Likewise, other companies think
that maybe the best thing to do
is to take their org chart and
sort of push it into the folder
structure and use that.
We find that the best
hierarchies don't
do either of those, and
instead they sort of
build off of two concepts.
The first concept is delegating
authority as Sarui mentioned,
and the second is grouping
resources of like risk
together where you can apply
similar security policies
to the same sets of resources.
To show you what that
looks like here's
a simple organization here.
A simple company that's decided
to build a couple applications
inside of Google
Cloud, app1 and app2.
In order to provide delegated
authority they created folders
to represent each of
their applications
and underneath
the applications--
and this is a representation
of delegating authority
to those teams. --they
granted the service
teams that manage app1 and
app2 access to those photos.
Below the folders there
are separate projects,
each of them indicating whether
the resources within are
pre-production development
environment resources
or whether they're production
resources with critical data.
And then this is
a sense grouping
resources in accordance to their
security profile and security
risk.
The pre-fraud environments don't
need to be lockdown super hard.
All the developers
can have access
to deploy code,
access data, whatever
they need to debug and
develop their system.
The production environment
on the other hand
is going to be locked
down much more tightly.
Only the on-callers are
going to have access
to fiddle with these projects
and their production systems
are going to be responsible
for pushing coding
and data to these environments.
Once an application
scale is large enough
you can imagine continuing
to apply the hierarchy
to break down the application
and manage the complexity
they're in.
Here, for instance,
the application two
has broken itself into two
sub-components, a front end
and a back end, for instance,
and the administrators
of application two were
responsible or delegating
authority to the front end
team and the back end team
to manage those
projects independently.
And they'll set those
things up without having
to come back to
the administrator
to have to configure it.
Now, to look at a more
complicated example using
both IAM policy and
organization policy,
you can do some
pretty cool things.
So here we have a
large organization,
fairly complicated.
There're numerous teams,
numerous organization,
numerous applications
within their hundreds
of projects,
potentially thousands.
As a security administrator
this makes me nervous.
They're all deploying
virtual machines.
I have no idea what
they're deploying.
I want to make sure that
my company is making sure
that the only things that
are running inside those VMs
are trusted code.
I need to put down an
operating system standard.
I need to make sure that it's
running all the daemons, all
the logging, all the security
protection infrastructure
that I need into those
operating systems.
I need to make sure
that all the developers
inside my organization
are using those images.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to hire an image team.
I probably have one already.
I'm going to pull off a
section of my policy hierarchy
and I'm going to grant
access to my image team
to manage those images.
They're going to create some
images, test them, vet them,
and then they're going to
publish them to this project
and share those resources with
the rest of my organization.
Now I can apply an
organizational policy called
Trusted Image Projects to
the rest of my organization
to lockdown and make sure that
the only operating systems
that only boot disks that
can be used in my compute VMs
are created and pushed by
the Golden Images Project.
And this allows me to have faith
and confidence in the software
that's running in my cloud.
I'll wait for a photo.
So now that we have
a policy hierarchy,
the next big question that
a lot of customers have is,
how do I figure
out how to assign
the roles to my employees and
my services, and grant access?
Now, this is a hard problem.
This is fundamentally
the most difficult part
of managing access control
and security in our system.
You need to essentially
have someone
who's capable of making
sense of the system
and granting access that's
appropriate for business
requirement to the
service or the user that's
getting such access.
I can't just make
that problem go away.
I'm sorry.
But we can help
you a little bit.
We can help you build a set of
standards for deploying access
grants that make sense for you.
So as you come to
Google Cloud, you've
probably encountered what we
call the primitive roles called
owner, editor, and viewer.
And these come out of the box.
They're extremely
broad grants of access.
We don't recommend
using them for anything.
It's a production system.
They're only there
to get you started
and to help you kick
the tires essentially.
And the reason that
they're not recommended
is because they
don't satisfy what
we call the principle
of least privilege,
wherein you grant
an access that's
commiserate with the minimum
requirements for each employee
and service in your system.
Now, when you're
designing roles it's
important to remember again that
you don't want to specifically
identify every single permission
and every single object
that the employee is
going to have to access.
In general we find there's
like a Goldilocks zone
where you are going to grant
reasonable level access that
contains all of the sets
of things that are in line
with the business
requirements of the user,
of the engineer or the
service that you're deploying.
You don't want to be
too strict and you
don't want to be to loose.
Now, nine out of 10
security engineers
love our pre-defined roles
to achieve this purpose.
They're designed
by Google engineers
and PNs based on
feedback we've gotten
from all of our customers.
They're representative the
kinds of roles in segregations
of access and responsibility
that our customers
have been asking for.
They've been applying
to their own resources.
And so, for instance,
here you can
see compute has provided
you with a number of roles
such as instance admin, network
admin, and load balancer admin,
because these are roles
that are naturally
managed by separate
individuals in a large number
of organizations.
The network administrator is
responsible for making sure
that the firewalls are locked
down, and so forth and so on.
Whereas the instance admin is
responsible for making sure
that the Hadoop cluster is
up and running, for instance.
Now, that final
security engineer
who wasn't happy enough
with the predefined roles
is usually satisfied and made
happy with our custom roles.
They're used in
special circumstances
where the predefined roles
don't line up exactly
with your business requirements.
For instance, we find
that a lot of customers
will combine a number
of predefined roles
into a single
role, a custom role
so that they can
grant it more easily
and make sure that
all sets of accesses
are present on any resource
which they grant this access.
Another common pattern is
that a security engineer sees
a predefined role that exactly
matches their requirements,
but there's that
one weird permission
inside that they
really don't want,
so they want to take that
away from their engineers.
Now, when you're granting
access and assigning
roles to your
employees and services
it's quite easy to figure out
when you've gotten it wrong
and you've under provisioned
the access to your resources.
The engineers and
the service are
going to complain in
one way or another,
and you're going to get
a ticket or something
to fix the assignment of
authority, fix the grants.
But if you've over provisioned
you don't get any notice.
No one comes along and tells
you I have too much power.
I'm so sorry.
Could you take some away?
I'm happy to let you know
that we're rolling out
tools that are going to help you
adjust these kinds of problems.
One is, for instance, called
the IAM role recommender which
looks at the access patterns
of users and services
in your system, in your cloud,
and based on historical traffic
gives you a future prediction
of what kinds of roles
you might want to have
instead given to the user.
And this allows you to make
more fine grain access control
and apply the principle of
these privilege in your cloud
at scale.
So now another kind of
problem that we see--
and it happens to everyone.
It happens to us.
It happens to me.
It happens to our customers.
--they often will get into a
situation in which they'll find
a policy that looks like this.
And it's hard to make sense
of why this policy looks
the way it looks.
Here you can see a number of
engineers have different levels
of access to this project.
I have no idea why any
of these roles exist.
Some companies have
constructed spreadsheets
to try to keep track of
the historical reasons
about why every one of these
grants have been created.
That's one strategy.
The strategy we
recommend instead
is to use what we
call a security
group based model which sort
of models the Rbac philosophy.
Instead of granting
roles to users
individually in an ad hoc
way, what we recommend
is you create security
groups that represent
the conceptual roles
and responsibilities
each engineer might
have to a resource.
Here, for instance,
team grilled cheese
has been broken down into
data scientists, debuggers,
and on-callers.
Now I can grant access to that
project to each of these roles
and responsibilities
based on what
they should have access to.
Data scientists get to run
through the prediction engine,
debuggers get to
run some queries
and access some other
data, and on-callers
get to do everything they want.
Yeah.
And then I can
independently manage
the sets of users
and services that
are members of the
security groups,
and then I can audit each of
these categories independently.
It's often usually much easier
to understand whether Cache
belongs to team grilled cheese
than it is to decide whether he
should have AutoML predictor
on some random project
in your organization.
Before I go on from role
construction and role
assignment I'd like to talk
about one other pattern
that we've been seeing
a lot of benefits from.
That's break glass success.
So one of the
common failure modes
that organizations
both inside of Google
and outside of Google
encounter with Google Cloud
is that senior engineers
and on-call engineers
end up getting
lots of privileges
on production resources.
Often they're an owner or often
they have administrator rights
and they carry this as what
we call ambient authority.
What this means is that it's
quite easy for an on caller
to accidentally visit the
wrong project, for instance,
and do something destructive
to that project thinking
they might have been
working on another project.
This is not a great
situation, especially when
your business is on the line.
What we recommend instead
is creating some sort
of break glass pattern
for this kind of access
for privileged access.
One way you can do this is
with predefined IAM roles
such as a project IAM Admin.
Project IAM Admin does
not give you the ability
to do anything on a project
except for set policy
and change the policy.
So instead of wandering
over to the Cloud console
and deleting some VMs, they have
to contemplatively first grant
themselves access to delete a
VM and then go and delete a VM.
We find that the break
glass pattern is actually
enhanced and made
a lot more secure
by application of automation.
And you can use automation such
as Jenkins, Terraform, Cloud
Functions, anything
that you have in house
to facilitate both the
breaking of the glass,
possibly with a ticketing
system or even an audit
and review process to make
sure that the escalation
of privileges is appropriate,
and then also to repair
the glass, to take away the
access when the incidents are
resolved.
Now that we've dealt
with roles let's deal
with securely accessing
my cloud, my VMs.
So securely accessing
data to and from my VMs
involves three
categories of access.
The first thing
I need to do is I
need to be able to SSH
into and connect to my VMs
and figure out what's
going on sometimes.
Second, I need to be able to
get securely from my VMs--
workloads in my VMs
need to securely get
to Google APIs to access
storage and workflow
engines and all the other
products that we offer.
And finally, your VMs
will need to phone home
and make calls to your on
prem services or to other VMs
or to VMs running in other
clouds, and do so securely.
I'm going to go through
each of those in turn here.
Oh, wait.
Did you feel that, Sarui?
It was like a disturbance, as
if a million credentials were
just created and
suddenly silenced
because they were published to a
GitHub repository in the cloud.
Breaks my heart.
This is what we
want you to avoid.
In particular,
unmanaged credentials
is one of the greatest
security threats
that we've seen in almost
all cloud activity.
When we work with our
customers we strongly
encourage you to use
fully managed credentials
in every circumstance that you
can, where the platform takes
care of rotating credentials,
keeping them in escrow
and protecting those
credentials from loss or leakage
or publishing to a
repository in the sky.
And so do this, first, let's
look at the SSH'ing to my VM
scenario.
I just deployed a
10,000 VM cluster.
It was doing something cool,
trust me, but five of those VMs
stopped working and
I need my on-callers
to be able to get into
those VMs and figure out
what was going wrong.
So some customers will
go and push some SSH keys
around into those VMs, but
the downside of that approach
is that when those
keys are lost or leaked
or an employee who had access
to a key leaves your company,
you're now stuck
with a key that's
leaked that an employee
that left your company
might still be able
to SSH into your VMs.
Instead, we'd like to recommend
that our customers use
what we call OS Login.
It's a product in
the Compute system
which you can enable by--
when you create your VMs,
you can enable it
by setting metadata
on your virtual machine.
You enable OS Login
and enable OS Login
two-factor authentication,
which requires
that your engineers provide
a security key whenever
they SSH into a VM.
And then you can control
access to your virtual machines
using IAM permissions, using the
OS Login, or the OS admin login
roles.
And the difference being
whether you let them
log in as themselves
or as root users.
And if you put
this all together,
you have complete assurance
that all access to that VM
is tied to the user lifecycle.
When the user leaves your--
when my [? on-caller ?]
leaves my company,
for whatever reason, the access
to the key that they have
doesn't matter anymore.
They can take that key
and publish it to GitHub
and it still doesn't give
them access to my VMs.
Next, we want to talk about
authenticating my VM securely
to my Google APIs and
my Google resources.
To achieve this
task, what we do is
what we call binding a service
account to a virtual machine.
The first step is to
create a service identity
in the Google Cloud console.
The second step is to
grant that service identity
access to all the things that I
think my workload needs access
to.
Third and finally, when I'm
creating the virtual machine
I select which
service account I want
that virtual machine to run as.
Every access that's made with
client libraries running inside
of that virtual
machine authenticates
the cloud as the service
account identity.
The long-term keys are held
in escrow and the only things
that the workload in
the virtual machine
gets is a short-term
access token, which can
be used to apply to API calls.
Now, one of the
common difficulties
with using this feature is
something called access scopes.
It's something that
you're required to select
when using the feature.
It is a great source of
confusion to customers,
we find.
The default is set to allow
default access, which isn't
always the easiest to use.
We recommend instead
using "allow full access
to cloud APIs" and what we
call the Cloud Platform scope.
This ensures that you have
easy access to call APIs.
It's a tool to effectively
make client library
integration simpler.
And then use IAM
permissions and IAM roles
granted to the service account
as your security feature.
Now, talking about VMs
that need to phone home.
A lot of times, you're
going to be running
only part of your workload
on Compute and some of it's
going to be running elsewhere.
To address that
particular problem,
we use the same approach
that we used for calling
into Google APIs previously.
You'd create a service account,
you attach it to the VM
when you've constructed it.
The code in the VM can then
get an OIDC Access Token,
which is an industry standard
compliant OpenID Connect
token that can be
verified by verifying
the signature in the token with
the OIDC endpoint for Google.
And the token contains
all the information
that you could
ever possibly need
to authorize access to this VM.
It contains the
service identity,
it contains the project ID, the
zone, the VM name, the creation
date, everything you
possibly ever need.
Again, it's
standards-compliant so it
works with all open source
OIDC-compliant libraries.
It gives you strong
proof of identity,
and again, you don't have
to manage credentials.
So everyone's safe.
Next, I'd like to talk about
other kinds of threats.
Other kinds of
organizational threats
to your virtual machine fleet.
In particular,
rootkits and bootkits.
When you have people
who can SSH in
or malicious software
that can hack
its way into the
front door, you always
have a risk that the software
that you're running in your VM
fleet is not the
software you think
it is unless you have a strategy
to make sure that it is.
And the approach to solve
that-- what you can use
is a product we call Shielded
VMs, which just launched to GA.
It allows for a
trusted chain of boot
from the virtual TPM of the
VM through the firmware,
through the operating
system, to make sure
that all the software running
in the operating system
has been vetted and vouched for.
If you have a rootkit that
installs random malware
into a kernel module in
your operating system,
we'll detect it and we'll
notify you and tell you
which VMs have
been hacked so you
can take remediative action.
To use this feature, you
can go to the boot disk
operating system
images on Compute
and you can filter
by the Shielded VM
provided operating
system images.
And then when you
create your VM,
you turn on the
Shielded VM option.
And you can notice
that this is an option,
and so you might worry, maybe
my developers cannot create
a Shielded VM.
And that's why we recommend
that you combine that
with the trusted boot pattern
that we showed you before
and organizational policies.
You can apply the same pattern
that we showed you before,
where you can have your
operating system images being
vetted and curated by your
images team, published
to your organization.
And then you can apply
an organizational policy
to the rest of your
organization to both require
that all VMs be created with
the Shielded VM feature.
And also, to ensure that
the only ones that are used
are the ones that you've
vetted and approved.
And again, to turn
that on you just
go to the organization policy
control panel in your Cloud
console and turn on Shielded
VMs and your trusted image
projects settings.
Should I go back?
Got to take a picture.
[INAUDIBLE] OK.
Finally, I'd like to
talk about setting up
secure-by-default
behaviors for your Cloud.
Like I said before, we are
sometimes in a tough spot
because we're trying
to sell a Cloud.
And to sell a Cloud, we need
to make it easy to use and also
secure at the same time.
To achieve this,
oftentimes the defaults
will come out of the box
with things easy to use.
You'll get the owner permissions
when you create a project
so you don't have to worry about
figuring out the permission
model just to deploy a function.
We do recommend that you
secure those projects
after you created them,
especially when they're
production resources.
Now, to achieve
this, what we find
is a factory pattern
works wonders.
And every one of our customers
that cares about security
seems to apply this mechanism
in one way or another.
The basic idea is, again, to
set up a workflow using Jenkins
or Terraform or Cloud
Function or whatever
it is, where your
employees, your developers,
can click on a button
hosted by you that
creates the resource in GCP.
And then sets up all the
configuration exactly
as you need it.
So for instance,
to achieve this,
you can first go to your
organization policy, your IAM
policy.
There, you'll find
a policy grant
that enables everyone
in your domain
to be able to create a project.
You can disable that.
Take that permission away.
Instead, you can grant that
permission to your workflow
engines that are allowed to
create vetted, secure projects.
Again, you can use
Jenkins and Terraform.
Anything you want.
And for us, some starting
points for thinking
about how you'd like to
make your default projects--
you could, for instance, delete
the default Compute service
account.
You can neuter its
permissions, which
start out with fairly
broad editor permissions.
You can delete the VPC network
that is created on the project
and instead connect that
project to a secured shared VPC
that you use for your
entire organization
or for sections of
your organization.
You can attach billing
accounts to make sure
that all the costs centering
goes to the right billing
account.
You can set up audit
logs and billing exports
to make sure that you have
full visibility as to what's
going on in those projects
when you unleash it
to your developers.
And again, this gives you
centralized governance
and control and guide
rails for your developers.
And it eliminates
all the challenges
of making your developers
get easy access--
rapid access-- to a
production environment,
or to develop their code,
or to create a production
environment.
And with that, I'll
hand it over to Sirui
to tell you more about
keeping track of what
your developers are doing.
SIRUI SUN: Thanks, Cache.
So, another type of question
we get from customers a lot
is, how do I more easily start
to understand everything that's
going on in my organization?
And this is a key part of
centralized administration
because in the
beginning, we talked
about how you can
extend permissions
to your organization,
to your org admin team,
for example, to view everything.
But that's not the
same thing as being
able to look over that
content in an easy way
to analyze what all is going on.
And so I want to start by
talking about some of the tools
that we offer to start giving
you that kind of 360 degree
view of your organization.
So, the first tool I
want to talk about--
this has been
around for a while--
are audit logs.
And I don't have time to get too
deep into the nuances of audit
logs, but I will talk
about a few types
that are really helpful for
this particular use case.
So, the first type
I want to talk about
are admin activity logs.
So, these logs are
generated whenever
an administrative
action is taken
on both the GCE resource but
also most other types of GCP
resources.
So for example, if I
had a user named Alice
and she created a VM in
a particular project,
we'll create an admin activity
log automatically for you.
And that will include
what type of VM
it was, what time it
happened, and other details
that give you more
visibility into what exactly
was happening.
These audit logs are enabled
by default in all projects.
In addition, they are
generated in real time.
So they really give
you that up-to-date,
up to the second details
about what all is going on
in your organization.
A second type of
audit log that's
important to know at this point
is the data access audit log.
So, these talk about data
reads and data accesses.
These tend to be a little bit
more verbose so they're not
turned on by
default. You actually
have to go and turn
them on yourself
but when you do so,
that information
will start flowing in.
And so in the use
cases where you're
really interested in knowing
even about the reads,
we highly suggest that
you turn these on.
So, with audit logs you get kind
of this moment-by-moment set
of events for your
entire organization.
And we release these and
we go to our customers
and they say,
well, this is good,
but it's difficult sometimes
to understand the precise state
of your world at a
particular moment in time
if I just have a set
of events leading up
to that particular
moment, right?
And it's possible to
construct that from audit logs
but it gets a little tricky.
And so in response
to that feedback,
we've actually recently
released a second tool
that we call the
Cloud Asset Inventory.
And this tool answers
the question of,
at a particular moment in time,
what resources and policies
were there in my organization,
in a particular folder,
or in a particular project?
This tool, this particular
API, will actually
look back in the last five
weeks so it has knowledge
of the last five weeks.
And so you can ask a
question like, hey,
last Saturday at 2:00 AM when
I had a security incident
or something like that, what
were the VMs that were running
in my organization?
And what were the policies
applied on those VMs?
And so you can start to do those
forensics-type investigations
or you can start--
you could imagine
you could use it for any
other number of use cases.
And it's great for
printing out that state.
Because it has knowledge of your
environment for the last five
weeks, it can also
tell you about how
a particular resource changed
over the past five weeks.
So, kind of like a
scrubbing over time,
you can see how a VM
might have evolved.
You can see who gained or
lost access to that VM.
And so you can think of these
as the two building blocks
to start getting an
understanding of what's
going on in your organization.
I won't delve too much
deeper here, other
than to say that we'll be
going much deeper into this
at tomorrow's session called
Best Practices for GCE
Enterprise Deployments.
Now, having released
both of these tools, what
we see a lot of times
is that customers
will go through and build
very similar solutions on top
of these building blocks.
They'll build solutions
to go and list out
all of the assets in
their organization
and they might also scan
the events and the assets
in their organization for
things that they don't
want to have happen, right?
Scan for vulnerabilities,
scan for that the right set
of firewall rules are
set up, et cetera.
And so in response
to that, we wanted
to deliver some of that
functionality out of the box.
And so we recently released to
beta the Cloud Security Command
Center.
This is going to provide a
lot of that functionality out
of the box.
It's going to be a single
pane of glass that's
going to let you understand
what resources are
in your organization, let you
explore what resources are
in your organization, and also,
it'll proactively be scanning
for vulnerabilities and
proactively informing you of,
for example, if you have
suspicious traffic going on,
if you have VMs with insecure
firewalls and things like that.
So based on the feedback we
got from what type of solutions
our customers built, based
on our building blocks,
we've built some of that
out of the box for you.
And if you want to
go further if you
want to modify that
or change something
based on your
security posture, you
can always go back to
your building blocks
and build that out from there.
Last section.
I want to talk a little
bit about the tools
that we provide you
as our customers
to ensure your
privacy and to ensure
that you're in full control
over your data in Google Cloud.
So one thing we hear
a lot from customers,
especially those in more
tightly regulated industries
like banking, is that they want
full control over their data
that they upload to the cloud.
It might be very sensitive.
They might be beholden to
regulatory needs to do so.
And one way that this translates
is, most of the times customers
ask for more control over
how their data is encrypted
in the cloud so that they
can manage that encryption
and so that they could,
for example, take away
the encryption keys protecting
their data so that no one has
access to that data anymore.
Not even us, Google.
So, the first thing
I want to talk
I want to say
before I proceed is
that by default all
data in Google Cloud
is encrypted at rest
regardless of configuration.
So even if you go in
and you don't configure
any of this data, any
of this encryption,
we'll still do it for
you automatically.
But we do give you the
tools to go further.
A best practice that's
quickly developing
is that customers can use
another managed service
that Google Cloud provides
called Google Key Management
Service.
This is a managed service that
allows you to manage keys.
So, you can create keys, rotate
keys, delete them at any time.
And then you can
apply these keys
to your disks, to your
images and snapshots,
and any other content
that you store in GCE.
And we'll start using
that key that you've
managed to go ahead and
start encrypting your data.
I should also note that
this whole flow is supported
with-- it's integrated with
IAM and audit logging, so
all the tools that
we just talked about.
So you can see who's
doing the encryption
and where these keys are.
And Cloud KMS has
a broad support
for all of the set
of security standards
that we've been hearing are
required from our customers.
So, what this looks like.
You would start by creating
a key and a key ring
in Cloud KMS.
That's a very quick task.
It should just take
you a few minutes.
And you can specify what the
rotation period of this key,
what encryption standard
it uses, et cetera.
And then when you go and
create a GCE disk or image
or snapshot, you will just
point GCE to that particular key
that you've just created.
And just like that, we'll
start using that particular key
to protect your data.
And so what that means
is as-needed later
you can go revoke or
disable access to that key.
This is what it looks
like both in the UI
and in the G Cloud
command line tool.
And from there, once you've
disabled access what you'll
find is that GCE will no longer
have access to that information
at all.
So if you try to attach a disk
that's protected by the revoked
key to a VM you'll see
that that action fails
and that will fail until you
restore access to the key.
And so in this way
you have full control
over who has access to
your data on Google Cloud.
Another question that we get
from customers is, well hey,
you're Google, how do I
know that you're not using
my data for other means, right?
How do I know you're not
using it to train some-- yeah,
you know, to advertise
or something like that.
Now, here I want to say
again that at Google Cloud,
we do not access your
data for any other reason
than those necessary to fulfill
our contractual obligations
to you.
And in fact, when we
looked at the data
internally, over 99% of when
we do these data accesses,
they're to fulfill
support requests.
So it's where
customers are actually
asking us to do these
to do these actions.
But you don't have to
take our word for it.
We have a feature called
Access Transparency logs.
They're another type of audit
logs that we just talked about.
And what they do
is they'll tell you
in near-real-time and
without cost any time
Google accesses your
data for any reason.
All right.
The one caveat
here is that these
are available for only a certain
subset of our support packages.
And you can find out
more details online.
But they're very easy to enable.
So as long as you have the right
permissions, that's step one--
we have a particular role
for this Access Transparency
admin--
you can just go into a
particular project folder
organization.
And you'll find a little
toggle in IAM admin settings.
And from there you
can go and you'll just
see that however you're
getting your logs,
maybe it's through the
Stackdriver Logging Portal,
you'll start seeing these
Access Transparency logs.
So, what does that look like?
Here's an example of an
Access Transparency log.
It will be generated
once for every action
that we take on your data.
And it will tell
you-- in yellow,
you can see it tells
you the reason,
so why did we access your data?
Here in particular,
we're doing this
because of a customer-initiated
support request.
And we'll attach the
case number for you.
And then in green you can
see what exactly Google did.
So you can see the resource
that we were operating on,
the API calls that we
made when we did this,
and a number of other
details relevant to the case.
And so, you don't have to take
our word for what I just said.
You can actually go in
and verify yourselves.
And so with that, that brings
us to the end of our talk.
We started by laying
down some principles,
and hopefully we've
been able to build up
to a set of best practices
to go apply those principles.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]